ein U-Boot braucht dringend Medikamente
ein Kriegsschiff braucht Verstärkung und
eine Allianz braucht bilder wie diese
wir sind unterwegs auf dem Mittelmeer
südlich von Antalya hier trainiert die
schnelle Eingreiftruppe der NATO
achteinhalbtausend Soldaten aus 13
Nationen eine Show auch für die Medien
man gibt sich gegenseitig beeindruckt
Chuckys
diese Übung zeigt sie wären in der Lage
und zu verteidigen wenn nötig
es ist eine ungewöhnliche Einladung der
wie am Morgen gefolgt sind ungewöhnlich
weil die türkische Armee selten Lust auf
kritische Begleitung hat jetzt aber
führt die Türkei diese NATO Großübung an
es ist die Chance für beide Seiten ein
Bild der Harmonie zu senden in Zeiten
der Dissonanz
es sind nicht mehr allein die westlichen
Sanktionen gegen Russland die der
türkische Präsident Erdogan ablehnt es
sind neuerdings auch scharfe Worte gegen
den NATO Verbündeten Griechenland die im
ganzen Bündnis irritieren
wir können eines Nachts plötzlich kommen
sie haben diese Inseln und dazu
Militärbasen auf den Inseln
seit Jahrzehnten streiten Griechenland
und die Türkei über Inseln in der Ägäis
über Hoheitsrechte und Bodenschätze
völkerrechtlich gehören die Inseln zu
Griechenland die Türkei wirft dem
Nachbarn vor die Inseln aufzurüsten
Griechenland sagt man tue das wegen der
Bedrohung aus der Türkei
wie schnell die Lage eskalieren kann
zeigen Bilder vom Wochenende
veröffentlicht von der türkischen
Küstenwache griechische
küstenschutzschiffe hätten einen
türkischen Frachter beschossen was
wirklich passiert ist wer weiß die NATO
ruft zur Messung
Ende differen Konflikte zwischen der
Türkei und Griechenland sollten
diplomatisch gelöst werden sie haben
dazu bei der NATO auch einen
entsprechenden Mechanismus entwickelt
die confliction man kann esse auf dem
türkischen Kriegsschiff sanchakda mit
dem wir an diesem Tag unterwegs sind
werden Kriegsdrohungen einfach
ausgeblendet keine Fragen zur Politik
hat man uns vorab gesagt nur zum Manöver
an dem aber nehmen auch griechische
Truppenteil also wie läuft die
Zusammenarbeit
wir sind sehr froh dass auch ein
griechisches Schiff an unsere Übung
teilnimmt sehr froh und ich denke sie
sind auch froh denn wir lernen
voneinander
der Höhepunkt der Show an diesem Tag
sind die Kampfjets doch selbst ihr
Dröhnen kann die Zweifel nicht
vertreiben an der Einigkeit die uns hier
vorgeführt wird